welcome to the RNN tutorial that's the
recurrent neural network my name is
Richard Kirchner I'm with the simply
learned team that's WW simply learn comm
get certified get ahead what's in it for
you we will start with the course of
fundamentals what is a neural network in
popular neural networks it's important
to know the framework we're in and what
we're gonna be looking at specifically
then we'll touch on why a recurrent
neural network
what is a recurrent neural network and
how does an RN in work one of the big
things about RN ends is what they call
the vanishing and exploding gradient
problem
so we'll look at that and then we're
gonna be using a use case study it's
going to be in course on tensor flow
cross is a Python module for doing
neural networks in deep learning and in
there there's see what they call long
short-term memory LS TM and then we'll
use the use case to implement our LS TM
on the cross so when you see that LS TM
that is basically the RN n network and
we'll get into that the use case is
always my favorite part before we dive
into any of this we're gonna take a look
at what is an RN n or an introduction to
the RN n do you know how Google's
autocomplete feature predicts the rest
of the words a user is typing I love
that autocomplete feature as I'm typing
away it saves me a lot of time I can
just kind of hit the enter key and it
auto fills everything and I don't have
to type as much well first there's a
collection of large volumes of most
frequently occurring consecutive words
this is fed into a recurrent neural
network analysis the data by finding the
sequence of words occurring frequently
and builds a model to predict the next
word in the sentence and then Google
what is the best food to eat in Los I'm
guessing you're gonna say los Mexico no
it's gonna be Las Vegas so the Google
search will take a look at that and say
hey the most common autocomplete is
gonna be Vegas in there and usually
gives you three or four different
choices so it's a very powerful tool it
saves us a lot of time especially when
we're doing a Google search or even in
Microsoft words has a it's some people
get very mad at it auto fills with the
wrong stuff but you know you're typing
away and it helps you out
Phil I have that in a lot of my
different packages it's just a standard
feature that we're all used to now so
before we dive in to the RNN and getting
into the depths let's go ahead and talk
about what is a neural network neural
networks used in deep learning consist
of different layers connected to each
other and work on the structure and
functions of a human brain you're going
to see that thread human in human brain
and human thinking throughout deep
learning the only way we can evaluate an
artificial intelligence or anything like
that is to compare it to human function
very important note on there and it
learns from a huge volumes of data and
he uses complex algorithm to train a
neural net so in here we have image
pixels of two different breeds of dog
one looks like a nice floppy eared lab
and one a German Shepherd you know both
wonderful breeds of animals that image
then goes into an input layer that input
layer might be formatted at some point
because you have to let it know like you
different pictures are going to be
different sizes and different color
content then I'll feed it into Hindley
errs so each of those pixels or each
pointed data goes in and then splits
into the hidden layer which then goes
into another hidden layer which then
goes to an output layer all right Ian
there's some changes in there which
we're gonna get into so it's not just a
straightforward propagation of data like
we've covered in many other tutorials
and finally you have an output layer and
the output layer has two outputs it has
one that lights up if it's a German
Shepherd and another the lights up it's
of its Labrador so identifies the dog's
breed set networks do not require
memorizing the past output so our
forward propagation is just that it goes
forward and doesn't have to remember I
stuff and you can see there that's not
actually me in the picture dressed up in
my suit I haven't worn a suit years it
says we're looking at this we're gonna
change it up a little bit before we
cover that let's talk about popular
neural networks
first there's the feed-forward neural
network used in general regression and
classification problems and we have the
convolution neural network used for
image recognition deep neural network
use for acoustic modeling deep belief
Network used for cancer detection and
recurrent neural network used for speech
recognition now taking a lot
these and mix them around a little bit
so just because it's used for one thing
doesn't mean it can't be used for other
modeling but generally this is where the
field is how this is how those models
are generally being used right now so we
talked about a feed-forward neural
network in a feed-forward neural network
information flows only in the forward
direction from the input notes through
the hidden layers if any into the output
notes there are no cycles or loops in
the network and so you can see here we
have our input layer I was talking about
how just go straight forward into the
hidden layers so each one of those
connects and then connects to the next
hidden layer it connects to the output
layer and of course we have a nice
simplified version where it has a
predicted output and the refer to the
input is X a lot of times in the output
as Y decisions are based on current
input no memory about the past no future
scope Y recurrent neural network issues
in feed-forward neural network so one of
the biggest issues is because it doesn't
have a scope of memory or time a
feed-forward neural network doesn't know
how to handle sequential data it only
considers only the current input so if
you have a series of things and because
three points back affects what's
happening now and what your output
affects what's happening that's very
important so whatever I put as an output
it's gonna affect the next one I'm a
feed-forward all it doesn't look at any
of that it just looks at this is what's
coming in and it cannot memorize
previous inputs so it doesn't have that
list of inputs coming in solution to
feed-forward neural network you'll see
here it says recurrent neural network
and we have our X on the bottom going to
H going to Y that's your feed-forward
but right in the middle that has a value
C so there's a whole another process was
memorizing what's going on in the hidden
layers and the hidden layers as they
produced data feed into the next one so
your hidden layer might have an output
that goes off to Y
but that output goes back into the next
prediction coming in what this does is
this allows it to handle sequential data
it considers the current input and also
the previously received inputs and if
we're going to look at general drawings
and solutions we should also look at
applications of the RNN image captioning
Arnon is used to caption image by
analyzing the activities present in it a
dog catching a ball in midair that's
very tough I mean you know we have a lot
of stuff that analyzes images
dog and the image of a ball but it's
able to add one more feature in there
that's actually catching the ball in
midair time series prediction any time
series problem like predicting the
prices of stocks in a particular month
can be solved using RNN we'll dive into
that in our use case and actually take a
look at some stock one of the things
they should know about analyzing stock
today is that it is very difficult and
if you're analyzing the whole stock the
stock market at the New York Stock
Exchange in the US produces some where
the neighborhood if you count all the
individual trades in fluctuations by the
second it's like three terabytes a day
of data so we're gonna look at one stock
just analyzing one stock is really
tricky in here we'll give you a little
jump on that so that's exciting but
don't expect to get rich off of it
immediately another application of the
RNN is natural language processing text
mining and sentiment analysis can be
carried out using iron in for natural
language processing and you can see
right here the term natural language
processing when you stream those three
words together is very different than
ice if I said processing language
naturally so the time series is very
important when we're analyzing
sentiments it can change the whole value
of a sentence just by switching the
words around or if you're just counting
the words you may get one sentiment
where if you actually look at the order
they're in you get a completely
different sentiment when it rains look
for rainbows when it's dark look for
stars both of these are positive
sentiments and they're based upon the
order of which the sentence is going in
machine translation given an input in
one language RNN can be used to
translate the input into a different
languages as output I myself very
linguistically challenged but if you
study languages and you're good with
languages you know right away that if
you're speaking English you would say
big cat and if you're speaking Spanish
you would say cat big so that
translation is really important to get
the right order to get there's all kinds
of parts of speech that are important to
know by the order of the words here this
person is speaking in English and
getting translated and you can see here
a person is speaking in English and this
little diagram I guess that's denoted by
the flags I have a flag I own it no but
they're speaking in English and it's
getting translated into
you Chinese Italian French German and
Spanish languages some of the tools
coming out are just so cool so somebody
like myself who's very linguistically
challenged I can now travel into worlds
I would never think of because I can
have something translate my English back
and forth readily and I'm not stuck with
a communication gap so let's dive into
what is a recurrent neural network
recurrent neural network works on the
principle of saving the output of a
layer and feeding this back to the input
in order to predict the output of the
layer sounds a little confusing we start
breaking it down I'll make more sense
and usually we have a propagation
forward neural network with the input
layers the hidden layers the output
layer with the recurrent neural network
we turn that on its side so here it is
and now our X comes up from the bottom
into the hidden layers into Y and they
usually draw very simplified X - H with
C as a loop a to Y where a B and C are
the perimeters a lot of times you'll see
this kind of drawing in here digging
closer and closer into the H and how it
works going from left to right you'll
see that the C goes in and then the X
goes in so the X is going upward bound
and C is going to the right a is going
out and C is also going out that's what
gets a little confusing so here we have
X n CN and then we have Y out and C out
and C is based on HT minus 1 so our
value is based on the Y and the H value
are connected to each other they're not
necessarily the same value because H can
be its own thing and usually we draw
this or we represent it as a function H
of T equals a function of C where H of T
- 1 that's the last H output and X of T
going in so it's the last output of H
buying with the new input of X where HT
is the new state F C is a function with
a parameter C it's a common way of
denoting it HT minus 1 is the old state
coming out and then X of T is an input
vector at time of step T well we need to
cover types of recurrent neural networks
and so the first one is the most common
one which is a one-to-one single output
one-to-one neural network is usually
known as a vanilla neural
Network used for regular machine
learning problems why cuz Vanilla's use
you considered kind of a just a real
basic flavor but because it's very basic
a lot of times they'll call the vanillin
neural network which is not the common
term but it is you know kind of a slang
term people will know what you're
talking about usually if you say that
then we run one-to-many so you have a
single input and you might have a
multiple outputs in this case image
captioning as we looked at earlier where
we have not just looking at it as a dog
but a dog catching a ball in the air and
then you have many to one network takes
in a sequence of inputs examples
cinnamon analysis where a given sentence
can be classified as expressing positive
or negative sentiments and we looked at
that as we were discussing if it rains
look for a rainbow so positive sentiment
where rain might be a negative sentiment
if you were just adding up the words in
there and then the course if you're
gonna do a one-to-one mini 2 1 1 2 mini
there's many to many networks takes in a
sequence of inputs and generates a
sequence of outputs example machine
translation so we have a lengthy
sentence coming in in English and then
going out in all the different languages
you know just a wonderful tool very
complicated set of computations you know
if you're a translator you realize just
how difficult it is to translate into
different languages one of the biggest
things you need to understand when we're
working with this neural network is
what's called the vanishing gradient
problem well training an RNN your slope
can be either too small or very large
and this makes training difficult when
the slope is too small the problem is
known as vanishing ingredient and you'll
see here they have a nice image loss of
information through time so if you're
pushing not enough information forward
that information is lost and then when
you go to Train it you start losing the
third word in the sentence or something
like that or doesn't quite follow the
full logic and what you're working on
exploding gradient problem oh this is
one that runs into everybody I mean
you're working with this particular
neural network when the slope tends to
grow exponentially instead of decaying
this problem is called exploding
gradient issues in gradient problem long
tracking time poor performance bad
accuracy and I'll add one more in there
your computer
you're a lower-end computer testing out
a model will lock up and give you the
memory error explaining gradient problem
consider the following two examples to
understand which should be the next word
in the sequence the person who took my
bike and blank a thief the students who
got into engineering with blank from
Asia and you can see in here we have our
x-value going in we have the previous
value going forward and then you back
propagate the error like you do with any
neural network and as we're looking for
that missing word maybe we'll cab the
person took my bike and blank was a
thief and the student who got into
engineering with a blank were from Asia
consider the following example the
person who took the bike so we'll go
back to the person took the bike was
blank a thief in order to understand
what would be the next word in the
sequence the RNN must memorize the
previous context whether the subject was
singular noun or a plural noun so was a
thief as singular the student who got
into engineering well in order to
understand what would be the next word
in the sequence the RNN must memorize
the previous context whether the subject
was singular noun or a plural noun and
so you can see here the students who got
into engineering with blank were from
Asia it might be sometimes difficult for
the arrow to back propagate to the
beginning of the sequence to predict
what should be the output so when you
run into the gradient problem we need a
solution the solution to the gradient
problem first we're going to look at
exploding gradient where we have three
different solutions depending on what's
going on one is identity initialization
so the first thing we want to do is see
if we can find a way to minimize the
identities coming in instead of having
it identify everything just the
important information we're looking at
next is to truncate the backpropagation
so instead of having whatever
information it's sending to the next
series we can truncate what it's ending
we can lower that particular set of
layers make those smaller and finally is
a gradient clipping so when we're
trading it we can clip what that
gradient looks like and narrow the
training model that we're using when you
have a vanishing gradient the option
problem we can take a look at weight
initialization very similar to the
identity but we're gonna
more weights in there so it can identify
different aspects of what's coming in
better
choosing the right activation function
that's huge so we might be activating
based on one thing and we need to limit
that we haven't talked too much about
activation function so we'll look at
that just minimally there's a lot of
choices out there and then finally
there's long short term memory networks
the ls TMS we can make adjustments to
that so just like we can clip the
gradient as it comes out we can also
expand on that we can increase the
memory Network the size of it so it
handles more information and one of the
most common problems in today's setup is
what they call long-term and
dependencies suppose we try to predict
the last word in the text the clouds are
in the and you probably said sky here we
do not need any further context it's
pretty clear that the last word is going
to be sky suppose we try to predict the
last word in the text I have been
staying in Spain for the last ten years
I can speak fluent maybe he said
Portuguese or French no you probably
said Spanish the word we predict will
depend on the previous few words in
context here we need the context of
Spain to predict the last word in the
text it's possible that the gap between
the relevant information and the point
where it is needed to become very large
LST M's help us solve this problem so
the LST M asks are a special kind of
recurrent neural network capable
learning long-term dependencies
remembering information for long periods
of time is their default behavior all
recurrent neural networks have the form
of a chain of repeating modules of
neural network connections in standard
RN ends this repeating module will have
a very simple structure such as a single
tangent each layer LST M asses also have
a chain length structure but the
repeating module has a different
structure instead of having a single
neural network layer there are four
interacting layers communicating in a
very special way LS TMS are a special
kind of recurrent neural network capable
of learning long term dependencies
remembering information for long periods
of time is their default behavior LS TMS
is also have a chain like structure but
the repeating module has a different
structure instead of having a single
neuron
Network layer there are four interacting
layers communicating in a very special
way as you can see the deeper we dig
into this the more complicated the
graphs get in here I want you to note
that you have x at t minus 1 coming in
you have exit e coming in and you have
at x at t plus 1 and you have h of t
minus 1 and h of t coming in and H of T
plus 1 going out and of course on the
other side is the output a in the middle
we have our tangent H but it occurs in
two different places so not only when
we're computing the X of T plus 1 are we
getting the tangent H from X of T but
we're also getting that value coming in
from the X of t minus 1 so the short of
it is as you look at these layers not
only does it does the propagate through
the first layer goes into the second
layer back into itself but it's also
going into the third layer so now we're
kind of stacking those up and this can
get very complicated as you grow that in
size and also grows in memory too and in
the amount of resources it takes but
it's a very powerful tool to help us
address the problem of complicated long
sequential information coming in that we
were just looking at in the sentence and
when we're looking at our long short
term memory network there's three steps
of processing in the ls TMS and we look
at the first one is we want to forget
irrelevant parts of the previous state
you know a lot of times like you know is
as in a unless we're trying to look at
whether it's a plural noun or not they
don't really play a huge part in
language so we want to get rid of them
then selectively update cell state
values so we only want to update the
cell state values that reflect what
we're working on and finally we want to
put only output certain parts of the
cell state so whatever is coming out we
want to limit what's going out to let's
dig a little deeper into this let's just
see what this really looks like so step
one decides how much of the past it
should remember first up in the LST n is
to decide which information to be
omitted in from the cell in that
particular time step it is decided by
the sigmoid function it looks at the
previous state H at t minus 1 and the
current input exit e and computes the
function so you can see over here we
have a function of t equals the
would function of the weight of F the H
at t minus 1 and then X of T plus of
course you have a bias in there with any
veneral network so we have a bias
function so f of T equals forget gate
decides which information to delete that
is not important from the previous time
step considering an LS TM is fed with
the following inputs from the previous
and present time step Alice is good in
physics John on the other hand is good
in chemistry so previous output John
plays football well he told me yesterday
over the phone that he had served as a
captain of his college football team
that's our current input so look at this
the first step is the forget gate
realizes there might be a change in
context after encountering the first
full stop compares with the current
input sentence of X of T so we're
looking at that full stop and then
compares it with the input of the new
sentence the next sentence talks about
John so the information on Alice is
delete it ok that's important to know so
we have this input coming in and if
we're going to continue on with John
then that's going to be the primary
information we're looking at the
position of the subject is vacated and
is assigned to John and so in this one
we've seen that we weeded out a whole
bunch of information and we're only
passing information on John since that's
now the new topic so step two is then to
decide how much should this unit add to
the current state in the second layer
there are two parts one is a sigmoid
function and the other is a tangent H in
the sigmoid function it decides which
values to let through zero or one
tangent H function gives the weight is
to the values which are passed to
setting their level of importance minus
one to one and you can see the two
formulators that come up the eye of t
equals the sigmoid of the weight of i h
of t minus 1 X of T plus the bias of I
and the C of T equals the tangent of H
of the weight of C of H of t minus 1 X
of T plus the bias of C so RI of T
equals the input gate determines which
information to let through based on its
significance in the current time step if
this seems a little complicated don't
worry because a lot of the programming
is already done when we get to the case
study understanding though that this is
part of the program is important when
you're trying to figure out these what
to set your settings at
you should also note when you're looking
at this it should have some semblance to
your forward propagation neural networks
where we have a value assigned to a
weight plus a bias very important steps
than any of the neural network layers
whether we're propagating into them the
information from one to the next or
we're just doing a straight forward
neural network propagation let's take a
quick look at this what it looks like
from the human standpoint as I step out
in my suit again consider the current
input at X of T John plays football well
he told me yesterday over the phone that
he had served as a captain of his
college football team that's her input
input gait analysis the important
information John plays football and he
was a captain of his college team is
important he told me over the phone
yesterday is less important hence it is
forgotten this process of adding some
new information can be done via the
input gate now this example is as a
human form and we'll look at training
this stuff in just a minute but as a
human being if I wanted to get this
information from a conversation maybe
it's a Google Voice listening in on you
or something like that how do we weed
out the information that he was talking
to me on the phone yesterday well I
don't want to memorize that he talked to
me on the phone yesterday or maybe that
is important but in this case it's not I
want to know that he was captain of the
football team I want to know that he
served I want to know that John plays
football and he was a captain of the
college football team those are the two
things that I want to take away as a
human being again we measure a lot of
this from the human viewpoint and that's
also how we try to train them so we can
understand these neural networks finally
we get to step three decides what part
of the current cell state makes it to
the output the third step is to decide
what will be our output first we run a
sigmoid layer which decides what parts
of the cell state make it to the output
then we put the cell state through the
tangent H to push the values to be
between minus 1 and 1
and multiply it by the output of the
sigmoid gate so when we talk about the
output of T we set that equal to the
sigmoid of the weight of zero of the H
of t minus 1 and back one step in time
by the X of t plus of course the bias
the H of T equals the out of t times the
tangent of the tangent H of C of T so
our own Z
put gate allows the past in information
to impact the output in the current time
step let's consider the example to
predicting the next word in the sentence
John played tremendously well against
the opponent and won for his team for
his contributions brave blank was
awarded player of the match there could
be a lot of choices for the empty space
current input brave is an adjective
adjectives describe it now John could be
the best output after brave thumbs up
for John awarded player of the match and
if you were to pull just the nouns out
of the sentence team doesn't look right
because it's not really the subject
we're talking about contributions you
know brave contributions or a brave team
brave player brave match so you look at
this and you can start to train this
these this neural network so starts
looking at and goes oh no John is what
we're talking about so brave is an
adjective
John's gonna be the best output and we
give John a big thumbs-up and then of
course we jump into my favorite part a
case study use case implementation of
LST M let's predict the prices of stocks
using the LS TM network based on the
stock price data between 2012 2016 we're
gonna try to predict the stock prices of
2017 and this will be a narrow set of
data we're not going to do the whole
stock market he turns out that the new
york stock exchange generates roughly 3
terabytes of data per day that's all the
different trades up and down of all the
different stocks going on and each
individual one second to second or
nanosecond to nanosecond but we're gonna
limit that to just some very basic
fundamental information so don't think
you're gonna get rich off this today but
at least you can give an eye you can
give a step forward in how to start
processing something like stock prices a
very valid use for machine learning in
today's markets use case implementation
of LS TM let's dive in we're gonna
import our libraries we're gonna import
the training set and get the scaling
going now if you watched any of our
other tutorials a lot of these pieces
just start to look very familiar it's
very similar setup let's take a look at
that and just reminder we're going to be
using anaconda
but her notebook so here I have my
anaconda navigator when we go under
environments I've actually set up a
cross Python three six I'm in Python 3 6
and nice thing about anaconda especially
the newer version remember a year ago
messing with anaconda in different
versions of Python and different
environments anaconda now has a nice
interface and I have this installed both
on a bunt 2 Linux machine and on Windows
so it works fine on there you can go in
here and open a terminal window and then
in here once you're in the terminal
window this is where you going to start
installing using pip to install your
different modules and everything now
we've already pre installed them so we
don't need to do that in here but if you
don't have them installed in your
particular environment you'll need to do
that and of course you don't need to use
the anaconda or the Jupiter you can use
whatever favorite Python IDE you like
I'm just a big fan of this because it
keeps all my stuff separate you can see
on this machine I have specifically
installed one for chorus since we're
gonna be working with chorus under
tensorflow we go back to home I've
gotten up here to application and that's
the environment I've loaded on here and
then we'll click on the launch jupiter
notebook now I've already made jupiter
notebook have set up a lot of stuff so
that we're ready to go kind of like
martha stewart's in the old cooking show
so we want to make sure we have all our
tools for you so you're not waiting for
them to load and if we go up here to
where it says new you can see where you
can create a new Python 3 that's what we
did here and I need the set up so it
already has all the modules installed on
it and I'm actually renamed this if you
go under file you can rename it I'm
calling an RN in stock and let's just
take a look at start diving into the
coat let's get into the exciting part
now we've looked at the tool and of
course you might be using a different
tool which is fine let's start putting
that code in there and seeing what those
imports and uploading everything looks
like now first half is kind of boring
when we hit the Run button because we're
going to be importing numpy as NP that's
the number Python which is your numpy
array and the map plot library so we're
going to do some plotting at the end and
our pandas for our data set our pandas
as PD and when I hit run it really
doesn't do anything except for load
those modules just a quick note let me
just do a quick
draw here shift oh there we go you'll
notice when we're doing this setup if I
was to divide this up oops I'm gonna
actually let's overlap these here we go
this first part that we're going to do
is our data prep a lot of prepping
involved in fact depending on what your
system and since we're using chorus I
put an overlap here but you'll find that
almost maybe even half of the code we do
is all about the data prep and the
reason I overlap this with chorus let me
just put that down because that's what
we're working in is because chorus has
like their own preset stuff so it's
already pre built in which is really
nice so there's a couple steps a lot of
times that are in the chorus setup we'll
take a look at that to see what comes up
in our code as we go through and look at
stock and then the last part is to
evaluate and if you're working with
shareholders or classroom whatever it is
you're working with the evaluate is the
next biggest piece so the actual code
here crust is a little bit more but when
you're working with some of the other
packages you might have like three lines
that might be it all your stuff is in
your pre-processing in your data since
chorus has is cutting edge and you load
the individual layers you'll see that
there's a few more lines here and
crosses a little bit more robust and
then you spend a lot of times like I
said with the evaluate you want to have
something you present to everybody else
to say hey this is what I did this is
what it looks like so let's go through
those steps it says I got kind of just
general overview and let's just take a
look and see what the next set of code
looks like and in here we have a data
set train and it's going to be read
using the PD or panda's dot read CSV and
it's a Google stock price train dot CSV
and so under this we have training set
equals data set train eye location and
we've kind of sorted out part of that so
what's going on here let's just take a
look at and let's look at the actual
file and see what's going on there now
if we look at this ignore all the extra
files on this I already have a train and
a
test set where it's sorted out this is
important to notice because a lot of
times we do that as part of the
pre-processing of the data we take
twenty percent of the data out so we can
test it and then we train the rest of it
that's we use to create our neural
network that way we can find out how
good it is but let's go ahead and just
take a look and see what that looks like
as far as the file itself and I went
ahead and just open this up in a basic
WordPad and text editor just so we can
take a look at it certainly can open up
an Excel or any other kind of
spreadsheet and we note that this is a
comma separated variables we have a date
open high low close volume this is the
standard stuff that we import into our
stock and we're the most basic set of
information you can look at in stock
it's all free to download in this case
we downloaded it from Google that's why
we call it the Google stock price and it
specifically is Google this is the
Google stock values from as you can see
here we started off at 1/3 2012 so when
we look at this first set up up here we
have a data set train equals PD inter
score CSV and if you noticed on the
original frame let me just go back there
they had it set to home Ubuntu downloads
Google stock price train I went ahead
and change that because we're in the
same file where I'm running the code so
I've saved this particular Python code
and I don't need to go through any
special pass or how the full path on
there and then of course we want to take
out certain values in here and you're
going to notice that we're using our
data set and we're now in pandas so
pandas basically it looks like a
spreadsheet and in this case we're gonna
do I location which is going to get
specific locations the first value is
going to show us that we're pulling all
the rows and the data and the second one
is we're only gonna look at columns 1 &
2 and if you remember here from our data
as we switch back on over columns we saw
we start with 0 which is the date and
we're gonna be looking at open and HI
which would be 1 & 2 we'll just label
that right there so you can see now when
you go back and do this you certainly
and extrapolate and do this on all the
columns but for the example let's just
limit a little bit here so that we can
focus on just some key aspects of stock
and then we'll go up here and run the
code and again I said the first half is
very boring whenever you hit the Run
button it doesn't do anything because
we're still just loading the data and
setting it up
now that we've loaded our data we want
to go ahead and scale it we want to do
what they call feature scaling and in
here we're gonna pull it up from the SK
learn or the SK kit pre-processing
import min max scaler and when you look
at this you gotta remember that
biases in our data we want to get rid of
that so if you have something that's
like a really high value let's just draw
a quick graph and I have something here
like that maybe the stock has a value
one stock has a value of 100 and another
stock has a value of 5 you start to get
a bias between different stocks and so
when we do this we go ahead and say ok a
hunter is gonna be the max and 5 is
going to be the min and then everything
else goes and then we change this so we
just squish it down I like the word
squish so it's between 1 and 0 so 100
equals 1 or 1 equals 100 and 0 equals 5
and you can just multiply it's usually
just a simple multiplication we're using
multiplication so it's going to be minus
5 and then 100 divided or 95 divided by
1 so or whatever value is divided by 95
and once we've actually created our
scale we've tolling is going to be from
0 to 1 we will take our training set and
we're going to create a training set
scaled and we're going to use our scaler
SC we're going to fit we're going to fit
and transform the training set so we can
now use the SC this this particular
object we'll use it later on our testing
set because remember we have to also
scale that when we go to test our model
and see how it works and we'll go ahead
and click on the run again it's not
gonna have any output yet because we're
just setting up all the variables okay
so we paste the data in here and we're
gonna create the data structure with the
60 time steps
output first note we're running sixty
time steps and that is where this value
here also comes in so the first thing we
do is we create our X train and wide
train variables and we set them to an
empty Python array very important to
remember what kind of array were in what
we're working with and then we're gonna
come in here we're gonna go for I in
range 62 1258 there's our 60 60 time
steps and the reason we want to do this
is as we're adding the data in there's
nothing below the 60 so if we're gonna
use 60 time steps we have to start at
Point 60 because it includes everything
underneath of it otherwise you'll get a
pointer error and then we're gonna take
our X train and we're going to append
training set scaled this is a scaled
value between 0 and 1 and then as I is
equal to 60 this value is going to be 60
minus 60 is 0 so this actually is 0 to I
so it's gonna be 0 is 61 to 61 let me
just circle this part right here 1 - 61
to 262 and so on and so on
and if you remember I said 0 to 60
that's incorrect because it does not
count
remember starts at 0 so this is a count
of 60 so it's actually 59 important to
remember that as we're looking at this
and then the second part of this that
we're looking at so if we remember
correctly here we go we go from 0 to 59
of I and then we have a comma 0 right
here
so finally we're just gonna look at the
open value now I know we did put it in
there for 1 to 2 if you remember quickly
doesn't count the second one so it's
just the open value we're looking at
just open and then finally we have Y
train dot append training set I to 0 and
if you remember correctly I - or I comma
0 if you remember correctly this is 0 to
59 so there's 60 values in it so we do I
down here this is number 60 so we're
going to do this as we're creating an
array and we have 0 to 59 and over here
we have number 60 which is going into
the white rain it's being upended on
there and then this just goes all the
way up
so this is down here is a 0 to 59 and
we'll call it 60 since that's the value
over here and it goes all the way up to
12 58 that's where this value here comes
in that's the length of the data we're
loading so we've loaded two arrays we've
loaded one array that has which is
filled with arrays from 0 to 59 and we
loaded one array which is just the value
and what we're looking at you want to
think about this as a time sequence
here's my open open open open open open
what's the next one in the series so
we're looking at the Google stock and
each time it opens we want to know what
the next one 0 through 59 what's 61
through 6161 2 through 62 what's 62 and
so on and so on going up and then once
we've loaded those in our for loop we go
ahead and take X train and Y train
equals NP dot array X train NPRA why
train we're just converting this back
into a numpy array that way we can use
all the cool tools that we get with
numpy ring cluding reshaping so if we
take a look and see what's going on here
we're gonna take our X train we're gonna
reshape it Wow what that does reshape me
that means we have an array if you
remember correctly so many numbers by 60
that's how wide it is and so we're when
you do X train shape that gets one of
the shapes and you get X trained out of
shape of one gets the other shape and
we're just making sure the data is
formatted correctly and so you use this
to pull the fact that it's 60 by in this
case where's that value 60 PI $11.99 12
58 minus 60 1199 and we're making sure
that that is shaped correctly so the
data is grouped into 11 v 99 by 60
different arrays and then the one on the
end just means at the end because when
you're dealing with shapes and numpy
they look at this as layers and so the
int layer needs to be one value that's
like the leaf of a tree where this is
the branch and then it branches out some
more and then you get the leaf and peeta
reshape comes from and using the
shapes to form it we'll go ahead and run
this piece of code again there's no real
output and that will import our
different cross modules that we need so
from cross models we're gonna import the
sequential model dealing with sequential
data we have our dense layers we have
actually three layers we're gonna bring
in our dense RL STM which is what we're
focusing on and our drop out and we'll
discuss these three layers more in just
a moment but you do need the with the
LST I'm you do need the drop out and
then the final layer will be the dense
but let's go ahead and run this and
they'll bring Porter modules and you'll
see we get an error on here and if you
read it closer it's not actually an
error it's a warning
what is this warning mean these things
come up all the time when you're working
with such cutting-edge modules are
completely being updated all the time
we're not gonna worry too much about the
warning all it's saying is that the H
5py module which is part of Korus is
going to be updated at some point and if
you're running new stuff on cross and
you start updating your cross system you
better make sure that your h5 pi is
updated too otherwise you're gonna have
an error later on and you can actually
just run an update on the h5 pi now if
you wanted to not a big deal we're not
gonna worry about that today and I said
we were gonna jump in and start looking
at what those layers mean I meant that
and we're gonna start off with
initializing the RNN and then we'll
start adding those layers in and you'll
see that we have the LS TM and then the
drop out LS TM then drop out LS TM then
drop out what the heck is that doing so
let's explore that
we'll start by initializing the RNN
regressor equals sequential because
we're using the sequential model and
we'll run that and load that up and then
we're gonna start adding our LS TM layer
and some drop out regularization and
right there should be the Q drop out
regularization and if we go back here
and remember our exploding gradient well
that's what we're talking about the drop
out drops out unnecessary data so we're
not just shifting huge amounts of data
through the network so and so we go in
here let's just go ahead and add this in
I'll go ahead and run this and we had
three of them let me go ahead and put
all three of them in and then we can go
back over them there's the second one
and this put one more in let's put that
in
put two more in I'm into it I said one
more in but it's actually two more in
and then let's add one more after that
and as you can see each time I run these
they don't actually have an output so
let's take a closer look and see what's
going on here so we're gonna add our
first LS TM layer in here we're gonna
have units 50 the units is the positive
integer and it's the dimensionality of
the output space this is what's going
out into the next layer so we might have
60 coming in we have 50 going out we
have a return sequence because it is a
sequence data so I want to keep that
true and then you have to tell it what
shape it's in well we already know the
shape by just going in here and looking
at X train shape so input shape equals
the X train shape of 1 comma 1 makes it
real easy you don't have to remember all
the numbers that would put in 60 or
whatever else is in there you just let
it tell the regressor what model to use
and so we follow our STM with a drop out
layer now understanding the drop out
layer is kind of exciting because one of
the things that happens is we can over
train our network that means that our
neural network will memorize such
specific data that it has trouble
predicting anything that's not in that
specific realm to fix for that each time
we run through the training mode we're
gonna take point two or twenty percent
of our neurons they just turn them off
so we're only gonna train on the other
ones and it's gonna be random that way
each time we pass through this
we don't overtrain these nodes come back
in and the next training cycle we
randomly pick a different xx and finally
they see a big difference as we go from
the first to the second and third and
fourth the first thing is we don't have
to input the shape because the shapes
already the output units is 50 here this
out of the next step
automatically knows this layer is
putting out 50 and because it's the next
layer it automatically sets X n so 50 is
coming out from our last layer is coming
out you know goes into the regressor and
Chris hammer drop out and that's what's
coming into this one and so on and so on
and so the next three layers we don't
have to let it know what the shape is it
automatically understands that and we're
gonna keep the units the same we're
still gonna do 50 units it's still a
sequence coming through 50 units and a
sequence now the next piece of code is
what brings it all together let's go
ahead and take a look at that
and we're come in here we put the output
layer the dense layer and if you
remember up here we had the three layers
we had LST M drop out and dense dense
just says we're gonna bring this all
down into one output instead of putting
out a sequence we just know I want to
know the answer at this point and let's
go ahead and run that and so we in here
you notice all we're doing is setting
things up one step at a time so far we
brought in our way up here we brought in
our data we bought in our different
modules we formatted the data for
training it we've set it up we have our
wide X train and our Y train we have our
source of data and the answers where we
know so far we're gonna put in there we
reshape that we've come in and built our
cross we've imported our different
layers and we have in here if you look
we have what five total layers now cross
is a little different than a lot of
other systems there's a lot of other
systems put this all in one line and do
it automatic but they don't give you the
options of how those layers interface
and they don't give you the options of
how the data comes in cross is cutting
edge for this reason so even those a lot
of extra steps and building the model
this has a huge impact on the output and
what we can do with this these new
models from curraghs so we brought in
our dense we have our full model put
together and regressor so we need to go
ahead and compile it and then we're
gonna go ahead and fit the data we're
gonna compile the pieces so they all
come together and then we're gonna run
our training data on there and actually
recreate our regressor so it's ready to
be used so let's go ahead and compile
that and I go ahead and run that and if
you've been looking at any of our other
tutorials on neural networks you'll see
we're going to use the optimizer atom
atom is optimized for big data
there's a couple other optimizers out
there beyond the scope of this tutorial
but certainly atom will work pretty good
for this and loss equals mean squared
value so when we're training it this is
what we want to base the loss on how bad
is our error we're we're gonna use the
mean squared value for our error and the
atom optimizer for its differential
equations you don't have to know the
math behind them but certainly it helps
to know what they're doing and where
they fit in to the bigger models and
then finally we're going to do our fit
fitting the RN end to the training set
we have the regressor fit x train y
train epoch
and batch size so we know where this is
this is our data coming in for the X
train or Y train is the answer we're
looking for of our data are sequential
input epochs is how many times we're
gonna go over the whole data set we
created a whole data set of X train so
this is each each of those rows which
includes a time sequence of 60 and
bad-sized another one of those things
where chorus really shines is if you
were pulling this a from a large file
instead of trying to load it all into
RAM it can now pick smaller batches up
and load those in directly we're not
worried about pulling them off a file to
dig this isn't big enough to cause a
computer to much of a problem to run not
to straining on the resources but as we
run this you can imagine what happened
if I was doing a lot more than just one
column in one set of stock in this case
Google stock imagine if I was doing this
across all the stocks and I had instead
of just the open I had opened cloves
high-low you can actually find yourself
with about 13 different variables x 60 x
as a time sequence suddenly you find
yourself with a gig of memory you're
loading into your RAM which will just
completely you know if it's just if
you're not on multiple computers or
cluster you can start running into
resource problems but for this we don't
have to worry about that so let's go
ahead and run this and this will
actually take a little bit on my
computer it's an older laptop and give a
second to kick in there there we go all
right so we have epoch so this is gonna
tell me it's running the first run
through all the data and as it's going
through its batching them in 32 pieces
so 32 lines each time there's 1198 I
think I said 1199 earlier bits 1198 is
off by one and each one of these is 13
seconds so you can imagine this is
roughly 20 to 30 minutes run time on
this computer like I said it's an older
laptop running at 0.9 gigahertz on a
dual processor and that's fine what
we'll do is I'll go ahead and stop go
get it drink a coffee and come back and
let's see what happens at the end and
where this takes us and like any good
cooking show I've got I got in my latte
I also had some other stuff running in
the background so you'll see these
numbers jumped up to like 19 seconds 15
seconds but you scroll through and you
can see we've run it through a hundred
steps or a hundred epics so the question
is what does all this mean
one of the first things you'll notice is
that our law scan is over here it kind
of stopped at 0.0014 we can see it kind
of goes down until we hit about 0.01
four three times in a row
so we guessed our epoch pretty close
since our losses remain the same on
there so define that we're looking at
we're gonna go ahead and load up our
test data the test data that we didn't
process yet and a real stock price data
set test eye location this is the same
thing we did it when we prepped the data
in the first place so let's go ahead and
go through this code and we see we've
labeled it part three making the
predictions and visualizing the results
so the first thing we need to do is go
ahead and read the data in from our test
CSV you see I've changed the path on it
for my computer and then we'll call it
the real stock price and again we're
doing just the one column here and the
values from I location so it's all the
rows and just the values from these that
one location that's the open stock open
let's go ahead and run that so that's
loaded in there and then let's go ahead
and create we have our inputs we're
gonna create inputs here and this is all
look familiar this is the same thing we
did before we're gonna take our data set
total we're gonna do a little pandas can
cap from the data set train now remember
the end of the data set train is part of
the data going in let's just visualize
that just a little bit here's our train
data let me just put TR for train and it
went up to this value here but each one
of these values generated a bunch of
columns so it was 60 across and this
value here equals this one and this
value here equals this one and this
value here equals this one and so we
need these top 60 to go into our new
data so define that we're looking at
we're gonna go ahead and load up our
test data the test data that we didn't
process yet and a real stock price data
set test eye location this is the same
thing we did when we prepped the data in
the first place so let's go ahead and go
through this code and we see we've
labeled it part three making the
predictions and visualizing the results
so the first thing we need to do is go
ahead and read the data in from our test
CSV you see I've changed the path on it
from my computer and then we'll call it
the real stock price and again we're
doing just the one
column here in the values from I
location so it's all the rows and just
the values from these that one location
that's the open stock open let's go
ahead and run that
so that's loaded in there and then let's
go ahead and create we have our inputs
we're gonna create inputs here and this
is all look familiar because this is the
same thing we did before we're gonna
take our data set total we're gonna do a
little pandas concat from the data set
train now remember the end of the data
set train is part of the data going in
let's just visualize that just a little
bit here's our train data let me just
put TR for train and it went up to this
value here but each one of these values
generated a bunch of columns so it was
60 across and this value here equals
this one and this value here equals this
one and this value here equals this one
and so we need these top 60 to go into
our new data because that's part of the
next data or it's actually the top 59 so
that's what this first set up is here we
here is we're going and we're doing the
real stock price and we're going to just
take the data set test and we're gonna
load that in and then the real stock
price is our data test test location so
we're just looking at that first column
the open price and then our data set
total we're gonna take pandas and we're
going to concat and we're gonna take our
data set train for the open and our data
set test open and this is one way you
can reference these columns we've
referenced them a couple different ways
we reference them up here with the one
two but we know it's labeled as a panda
set is open so pandas is great that way
lots of versatility there and we'll go
ahead and go back up here and run this
there we go and you'll notice this is
the same as what we did before we have
our open data set we're pended are two
different or concatenated our two data
sets together we have our inputs equals
data set total length data set total
minus length of data set - test - 60
values so we're gonna run this over all
of them and you'll see why this works
cuz normally when you're running your
test set versus your training set you
run them completely separate but when we
graph this you'll see that we're just
going to be will be looking at the part
that we didn't train it with to see how
well it graphs and we have our inputs
equals inputs dot reshapes or reshaping
like we did before we're transforming
our inputs so if you remember from the
transform between 0 and 1 and
finally we want to go ahead and take our
X test and we're gonna create that X
test and for I in range sixty to eighty
so here's our X test and we're appending
our inputs I to 60 which remember zero
to 59 and I comma zero on the other side
so it's just the first column which is
our open column and once again we take
our X test we convert it to a number
array we do the same reshape we did
before and then we get down to the final
two lines and here we have something new
right here are these last two lines let
me just highlight those or or mark them
predicted stock price equals regressor
dot predicts X test so we're predicting
all the stock including both the
training and the testing model here and
then we want to take this prediction and
we want to inverse the transform so
remember we put them between 0 & 1 well
that's not going to mean very much to me
to look at it at a floating number
between 0 1 I want the dollar amounts I
want to know what the cash value is and
we'll go ahead and run this and you'll
see it runs much quicker than the
training that's what's so wonderful
about these neural networks once you put
them together it takes just a second to
run the same neural network that took us
about a half hour to train and plot the
data we're gonna plot what we think it's
going to be and we're gonna plot it
against the real data with the Google
stock actually did so let's go ahead and
take a look at that in code and this
poll is cold up so we have our PLT
that's our hope if you remember from the
very beginning let me just go back up to
the top we have our mat plot library
pipe lot as PLT that's where that comes
in then we come down here we're gonna
plot the medium get my drawing thing out
again okay go ahead and PLT is basically
kind of like an object it's one of the
things that always threw me when I'm
doing graphs in Python because I always
think you have to create an object and
then it loads that class in there well
in this case PLT is like a canvas you're
putting stuff on so if you've done html5
you'll have the canvas object this is
the canvas so we're gonna plot the real
stock price that's what it actually is
and we're gonna give that color red so
it's gonna be in bright red we're gonna
label it real Google stock price and
then we're gonna do our predicted stock
we're gonna do it in blue and it's gonna
be labeled predicted and we'll give it a
title so it's always nice to give a
title to your graph especially if you're
going to present this to somebody you
know to your shareholders in the
this and the xlabel is gonna be time
because it's a time series and we didn't
actually put the actual date and times
on here
but that's fine we just know they're
incremented by time and then of course
the white label is the actual stock
price PLT dot legend tells us to build
the legend on here so that the color red
and in real Google stock price show up
on there and then the plot shows us that
actual graph so let's go ahead and run
this and see what that looks like and
you can see here we have a nice graph
and let's talk just a little bit about
this graph before we wrap it up here's
our legend I was telling you about
that's why we have the legend to show
the prices we have our title and
everything and you'll notice on the
bottom we have a time sequence we didn't
put the actual time in here
now we could've we could have gone ahead
and plotted the X since we know what the
dates are and plotted this two dates but
we also know that it's only the last
piece of data that we're looking at so
last piece of data which in somewhere
probably around here on the graph it's
like about 20% of the data probably less
than that we have the Google price and
the Google price has this little up jump
and then down and you'll see that the
actual Google instead of a turn down
here just didn't go up as high and
didn't go down so our prediction has the
same pattern but the overall value is
pretty far off as far as stock but then
again we're looking at one column we're
only looking at the open price we're not
looking at how many volumes were traded
and like I was pointing out earlier we
talked about stock just right off the
bat there's six columns there's open
high low close volume then there's
weather
I mean volumes shares then there's the
adjusted open adjusted high and just at
low adjusted close they have a special
formula to predict exactly what it would
really be worth based on the value of
the stock and then from there there's
all kinds of other stuff you can put in
here so we're only looking at one small
aspect the opening price of the stock
and as you can see here we did a pretty
good job this curve follows the curve
pretty well it has like a little jumps
on it bins they don't quite match up so
this bin here does not quite match up
with that bin there but it's pretty darn
close you have the basic shape of it and
the prediction isn't too far off and you
can imagine that as we add more data
and look at different aspects in the
specific domain of stock we should be
able to get a better representation each
time we drill in deeper of course this
took a half hour for my program my
computer to Train
so you could imagine that if I was
running it across all those different
variables might take a little bit longer
to train the data not so good for doing
a quick tutorial like this so we covered
a lot of really cool things in this
tutorial today hopefully you'll be able
to get rich predicting stock or maybe
get a job if you are familiar with the
stock domain and business domain but you
can see how this would be applied to all
kinds of different tools and trades
across different domains so the biggest
takeaways are as we had an introduction
to the RNN and it's set up on there we
went over the popular neural networks
that are out there we discussed what is
a recurrent neural network we went into
one of the big problems with the RNN and
that's the exploding gradient problem we
also discussed the long short term
memory networks which is part of what
we're working on that's the the LST
which is part of the RNN setup and
finally we went through and we predicted
the Google stock to see how it did so I
want to thank you for joining us today
again my name is Richard Kirchner one of
these simply learned team that's WW
simply learn comm for more information
please visit our web site feel free to
ask any questions check out our
different courses we have you can also
place comments below in the YouTube
video and we will keep monitoring those
and try to address those again thank you
for joining us today hi there if you
like this video subscribe to the simply
learn youtube channel and click here to
watch similar videos to nerd up and get
certified click here